as world war ii was coming to an end in
the summer of 1945
an austrian-born professor working at a
german university named carl von frisch
was making a discovery that would later
earn him a nobel prize
von frisch was fascinated by honeybees
and through a series of clever
experiments he would show that bees can
communicate with one another through a
type of interpretive dance
von frisch's earlier work had shown that
honey have color vision
but now he was intrigued by the
behaviors he was observing inside the
beehive
von frisch took advantage of a way to
keep bees in a narrow space with a pane
of glass on the side called an
observation hive that was developed by
beekeepers to monitor the development of
queen bees
von frisch noticed that foraging honey
bees that just returned to the hive
repeatedly shake their abdomens in
consistent patterns
he believed the shaking which became
known as the waggle dance
was communicating some sort of
information about sources of food the
foraging bees had encountered
at first he assumed the foragers were
letting the other bees know what kind of
flowers they had found by shaking their
abdomens to spread the scent of the
flowers
to test this hypothesis
von frisch marked individual bees with
different colors of paint
he then placed baits with different
types of food like flowers or solutions
of scented sugar water
in different locations and made note of
which bees visited which bait
to his astonishment what von frisch
observed was that the beast changed
their waggle dance depending on which
food source they visited but it wasn't
the type of food that mattered but the
location of the food source
a bee performing a waggle dance moves in
a figure eight waggling its abdomen
during the middle portion where the two
loops that make the figure eight come
together
by carefully adjusting the location of
each food source von frisch figured out
that the further away the food is from
the colony the longer the bee waggles
before turning either right or left to
complete the figure eight
what's more
repeated experiments revealed that the
information being communicated was
precise
one second of waggling indicates a food
source that is about one kilometer away
from the hive
but if a bee wants to visit that food
source it not only needs to know how far
to fly but also in what direction
von frisch's experiments showed that the
angle at which the bees perform their
waggle dance tells the other bees which
way to fly when they leave the hive
entrance
specifically the angle with respect to
the vertical axis of the honeycomb
corresponds to the angle with respect to
the sun that the b should fly to find
the food
for example if a bee waggles at 10
degrees to the right of vertical
then the food can be found by flying 10
degrees to the right of where the sun
can be seen in the sky from the nest
entrance at that particular moment
knowing the direction and the distance
the other bees in the hive have all the
information they need to find the food
but why do bees share this information
with one another at all
honeybees are social insects and the
survival of any one bee is dependent on
the survival of the colony
honey bees are native to temperate
climates with cold winters
but unlike many insects that live in
cold climates honeybees don't go through
a dormant state known as diapause which
is similar to hibernation
to make it through the winter the
honeybees must keep their body
temperatures above 50 degrees fahrenheit
they do this by producing heat with
their wing muscles contracting the
muscles that raise each wing and the
muscles that lower each wing at the same
time
this muscle twitching doesn't make the
wings move that much but it generates
heat in much the same way as shivering
helps us to warm up a bit when we get
cold
an individual bee vibrating its wings
isn't enough to raise the surrounding
temperature significantly but when
thousands of bees vibrate their wings in
a small space the heat generated is
enough to keep all the bees alive
throughout the cold winter months
but all that muscle twitching burns
energy so the bees need a supply of high
energy food that is readily available
inside the hive all winter long
that's one of the most important reasons
honeybees make honey as a stockpile of
food that will keep them buzzing inside
the hive during winter keeping each
other warm like a living radiator
the size of the hive is another
important factor for the bees to survive
the winter
they need enough space to accommodate
all the worker bees as well as the
honeycomb and the combs that the bees
use to raise their larvae
but if the space is too large it won't
be possible to keep it warm with their
vibrating wings an average sized
honeybee colony with about 44 pounds of
honey will need about four gallons of
space perhaps a bit more to allow room
for expansion
bee keepers use artificial hives that
are larger than what the bees need
because the bees tend to fill the hive
with as much honeycomb as they can
meaning there is extra that can be
harvested
a single colony kept in a 36 gallon hive
can make more than 220 pounds of honey
in one summer
but in the wild honeybees have to find a
suitable place to live usually a small
cave or hollow space in a tree
each year as the colony grows the bees
must find a new slightly larger site to
build a new home
the way they locate these sites and
agree on which site is best
involves another remarkable example of
complex communication
the first person to notice this aspect
of honeybee communication was martin
lindauer a student of carl von frisch
one afternoon in 1949 lindauer noticed a
swarm of bees outside the zoological
institute in munich where he was
conducting his phd
some of the bees were performing waggle
dances but these bees were outside of
the hive which happens when the queen
and a group of workers are in search of
a new home
looking more carefully lindauer noticed
that some of the bees looked dirty he
collected some samples of the dirt and
examined it under a microscope
rather than being covered in pollen as a
foraging bee would the dirt from these
dancing bees looked like dust from
bricks and soot from chimneys
lindauer suspected that the bees he saw
dancing had been inspecting new nest
sites including the rubble from the many
buildings still left in ruins after the
war
he would later find out that his guess
was correct
by marking individual bees with dots of
colored paint deciphering the location
information contained in the waggle
dance they were performing and chasing
after the swarm as it flew towards the
site the colony had selected
lindauer discovered that the bees were
indeed dancing to report the location of
potential new homes
but with lots of real estate options to
choose from how does a colony of bees
determine which one is best
by offering swarming honey bees
artificial nests that differ in specific
ways and then observing which options
they choose
cornell university biologist thomas
sealy has figured out what properties
the bees find most important in a home
volume
honey bees prefer a home that is large
enough to accommodate all the bees and
their stored honey but not so big that
they can't keep it warm in winter
the optimal size is about one and a half
cubic feet
if the hive already has a honeycomb from
a previous colony of bees that makes it
even more desirable
entrance size honeybees need an entrance
to the hive that is small enough that it
can be easily defended if an enemy
attempts to enter and also to keep the
heat inside in winter but large enough
to make it easy for the bees to come and
go
the ideal size is an entrance between 2
and 12 square inches in area
entrance direction
honey bees living in the northern
hemisphere prefer south-facing entrances
which face the sun more directly and
help it stay warm in the winter
entrance height
to defend it from enemies like bears
honeybees prefer a hive with an entrance
about 15 feet off the ground they also
prefer that the entrance is near the
bottom of the cavity
sealy's work makes it clear that bees
have preferences but how does a colony
that consists of 10 000 individuals make
a decision about which home to choose
contrary to the way that bees are often
depicted in books and movies the queen
does not actually play any role in this
process
queen bees along with queen ants wasps
and termites do not oversee the efforts
of the worker bees in their colonies nor
do they assign them specific tasks
the queen's role is purely reproductive
a queen is an egg-laying machine a queen
bee can lay more than 1
500 eggs in a single day
she can control whether the eggs she
lays are fertilized by sperm stored in a
storage organ in her abdomen
if an egg is laid without being
fertilized it will develop into a male
called a drone
inside the nest the drones do little
more than eat honey
their primary role is reproduction
they leave the nest to look for young
queens from nearby colonies to mate with
eggs that the queen does fertilize
develop into females
whether the females become new queens or
workers depends on what they eat
all bee larvae are fed royal jelly a
nutritious substance secreted from
glands in the mouths of worker bees
larvae that are fed royal jelly
throughout their development develop
into queens
but most female larvae are switched to a
diet of honey and stored pollen called
bee bread after the first three days
the dietary switch causes these larvae
to develop into workers
they won't grow quite as large as a
queen and their reproductive organs will
atrophy
while workers lose their ability to
reproduce they will perform every other
task in the colony from collecting
pollen and nectar to rearing the young
and defending the hive against enemies
it's these worker bees that will also
make the decision about what new home to
choose
certain workers called scouts visit
different possible home sites and
evaluate them using the criteria that
bees care most about
entrance size location and
volume the scouts then return to the
swarm and perform a waggle dance to
indicate the location of the potential
new home
because there are numerous scout bees
typically a few hundred
many of them are likely to have found
different potential new homes
that means there are multiple different
waggle dances being performed at the
same time
representing different options for the
colony to choose from
the other scout bees observe the dances
by feeling the vibrations with their
antennae it's dark inside the hive so
they can't watch with their compound
eyes
the better a potential nest site is the
more vigorously the scout will dance
specifically scout bees advertising
particularly good nest sites will dance
faster and for a longer time
but the bees don't just accept the
opinions of the scouts
after watching a scout advertise a
potential home with its waggle dance the
other scouts then go to the site to
assess it for themselves
if they agree that the site meets all
the necessary criteria the scout will
return to the colony and join the first
scout in dancing to advertise this
location
in this way each scout b has the
opportunity to evaluate each of the
potential sites and those that are
better suited eventually end up having
more bees advocating for them with their
dances
eventually a consensus is reached in
which all the scout bees are dancing for
the same site
in this way a decision is reached and
the colony will soon fly off altogether
and get settled in the new home they
have chosen
the ways that honeybees make collective
decisions are similar to the way some
human organizations operate
annual meetings in many new england
towns have used a similar approach for
more than 300 years to make decisions
regarding budgets and the establishment
of local laws
like bees advocating for a new nest site
these open town meetings allow anyone to
share their opinion about an issue which
is then open for debate by all members
of the community
while everyone gets a vote a consensus
is often achieved by allowing each
person to listen to and evaluate all
competing arguments
this is very similar to the way bees
reach a consensus by observing each
waggle dance and then evaluating the
options before voting by performing
their own waggle dance
one of the most common ways that insects
communicate with one another is through
the use of chemicals called pheromones
like hormones pheromones are chemicals
that are made in specialized cells
within a gland and have an effect
somewhere else
but whereas hormones like epinephrine or
testosterone have an effect somewhere in
the body of the organism that produced
the hormone
pheromones are produced by one
individual and have an effect on another
individual
the french naturalist jean henry fabre
who had a flair for clever experiments
and provocative writing discovered the
power of pheromones by accident
after capturing a female moth and
keeping it alive in a small enclosure in
his home in southern france he was
shocked to later find his house filled
with male mods that had flown in through
an open window
noting that they had arrived at night
when it was dark outside fabra suspected
that the male moths were attracted by a
chemical cue given off by the female
are there he wrote in point of fact
effluvia similar to what we call odor
absolutely imperceptible to ourselves
and yet capable of impressing a sense of
smell better endowed than ours
to test this idea he put female moths in
different types of enclosures some of
which were tightly sealed and some of
which had small
openings no males arrived at the
enclosures of females kept in tightly
sealed containers but females kept in
enclosures with even the slightest
opening were swarmed by males
in another experiment fibra kept a
female moth in a wire mesh container
overnight then transferred her to a
glass container the next day
the male mod swarmed around the open
container where the female moth used to
be but ignored the container where she
could be seen but not smelled
fabric concluded that there must indeed
be a chemical that attracts the male
moths to the female
fabra's idea that moths use chemicals to
find mates remained unproven until 1959
when a german biochemist isolated a
substance called bombacol from female
silkworm moths
male moths that were presented with a
pure solution of bombocal began rapidly
flapping their wings performing what's
known as a flutter dance an indication
of their interest in mating
so fabra was right moths do use
chemicals to find mates
the term pheromone was coined in 1959
the same year that bambikal was isolated
it was the beginning of a golden age in
the study of how chemicals influence
insect behavior
the previous year in 1958 an american
naturalist named edward osborne wilson
reported a discovery of another way that
chemicals control insect behavior
wilson would eventually become a harvard
professor and pulitzer prize-winning
author with a passion for insects
especially ants
as a child wilson had hoped to study
birds but a fishing accident left him
blind in one eye
he turned his attention toward ants
which were abundant around his home in
alabama in which he could examine up
close with the help of microscopes
wilson became fascinated by their social
behaviors and wondered whether these
behaviors might be controlled by
chemicals
one behavior that wilson was curious
about was the way that dead worker ants
are removed from the colony and
deposited in a refuse pile
removing dead ants from the nest makes
sense they could spread disease but
wilson wondered what cues the ants used
to determine that an ant had died
he soaked pieces of paper in an extract
made from different chemicals isolated
from dead ants and gave each piece of
paper to live ants
wilson found that the live ants treated
the paper soaked in one particular
chemical oleic acid as if it were a dead
ant by carrying the paper to the refuse
pile
other items like food were also treated
as dead ants if they were soaked in
oleic acid
even live ants soaked in oleic acid were
carried off to the refuse pile
never mind that their legs were still
moving
wilson and colleagues would soon find
other chemicals that act as pheromones
and play important roles in ant behavior
alarm pheromones are used to signal an
emergency like a predator digging into
the nest
because the alarm pheromone released by
one individual can serve as a message to
many other individuals
each of which can in turn release
additional alarm pheromone the message
spreads very quickly through the colony
i know from experience how effectively
ants can defend their colony soon after
a threat is perceived
my field pants are covered in holes cut
by leaf cutter ant soldiers whose
massive heads power sharp jaws that can
slice through just about anything even
rubber boots
some ants also use trail pheromones to
let their nest mates know where they've
been
trail pheromones can be used like a
trail of breadcrumbs to make it easier
for foraging ants to find their way home
trail pheromones can also make finding
food more efficient by helping foraging
workers to take the shortest path from
their nest to a source of food
ants generally follow the path with the
strongest pheromone trail so even if
they choose their path randomly at first
ants following behind them will end up
choosing the shortest path because being
shorter more workers will have traveled
along it over a given amount of time
causing it to accumulate the most
pheromone
this simple but effective way to find
the shortest route between different
places has been used to solve human
problems too
a class of computer programs called ant
colony optimization uses virtual ants
and pheromones to virtually explore
different possible routes between
different points ant colony optimization
programs can quickly calculate the
fastest delivery routes or the most
effective design for a wireless network
sometimes ants from neighboring colonies
find the same food
this often leads to a fight and worker
ants use alarm pheromones to recruit
backup
like baseball or hockey players clearing
the bench when a fight breaks out ants
come pouring out of each nest to help in
the skirmish
ants can usually tell whether another
ant belongs to its nest by the way it
smells
chemicals called cuticular hydrocarbons
that make up part of the insect
exoskeleton serve as identity markers
making it easy for ants to determine
whether an ant is a nest mate or an
enemy
i've used this fact to have students map
the territorial boundaries between
different nests of fire ants
if you take two ants and put them
together in a neutral arena like a
plastic container you can quickly tell
whether the two ants came from the same
nest by whether or not they fight
that is unless one of the ants has a
particular mutation that makes them lose
the ability to recognize nest mates from
non-nest mates
the mutation affects a part of the
genome known as the social chromosome
the social chromosome includes a gene
called gp9 that makes a protein involved
in the ability to detect smells
the mutated version of gp9 causes ants
to lose the ability to smell cuticular
hydrocarbon cues
the result is that ants with the mutated
form of gp9 treat all other fire ants
they meet as if they are nest mates
the alternative would be to treat all
other ants as enemies which would lead
to constant fighting even with nest
mates
but the mutated gp9 gene has been one of
the factors that has allowed red
imported fire ants to spread across much
of the southern united states
this species whose scientific name is
solenopsis invicta is native to brazil
and argentina but was introduced to
north america as accidental stowaways in
soil or vegetation
fire ants have painful stings and some
people are allergic to their venom
making them a nuisance for most but
dangerous for some
red imported fire ants were first
detected in the u.s in 1942
by none other than ed wilson the harvard
biologist who would later help decipher
the chemical language of ants
at the time he was only 13 years old but
had already become an astute observer of
the natural world and recognized the
ants as something new
the fire ants quickly spread from the
point of their first arrival on the
alabama coast
by the 1970s they had made it west to
central texas and east to northern
florida
by the 1990s they had made it north to
tennessee and north carolina
one of the keys to their success has
been the fact that fire ants with the
mutated gp9 gene don't fight with their
neighbors the way ants normally do
this allows a new nest to become
established near existing colonies so
the total number of nests in an area can
be higher than it would otherwise be
another factor has been that fire ants
with the mutated gp9 gene tolerate
having more than one queen in the colony
a condition known as polygeny which is
unusual for fire ants
polygenous nests are harder to destroy
with poisons or toxic baits because you
have to kill all the queens
for fire ants avoiding conflicts between
nests has been a successful evolutionary
strategy
yet pacifists are rare among insects
especially ants
while most ant species act aggressively
toward any other ants they encounter
especially those of the same species
the desert honeypot ant mirmicocisistus
mimicus evolved a way to determine the
outcome of such encounters while
minimizing casualties
when workers from rival colonies of
desert honeypot ants encounter one
another they release alarm pheromones to
call for backup much like other ants
what's different about honeypot ants is
what happens next
rather than attacking one another the
workers line up and extend their legs
making them look as if they're walking
on stilts
they're literally sizing up the
competition
but rather than fighting one another
they have turned these confrontations
into ritualized tournaments
it's a way of figuring out which colony
would win if they did fight by using the
number of workers on each side as a
proxy for the total size of the colony
the tournaments can go on for days but
eventually a winner is determined based
on which colony recruits more ants to
the tournament site
if the victorious colony is only
somewhat larger then the competition
will end there
the victorious colony has won access to
the food in that particular territory
but if the colonies are very mismatched
that is if one colony is much bigger
then the losing colony is in serious
trouble
workers from the much larger colony will
raid the nest of the smaller colony kill
its queen and carry the workers larvae
and pupae back to their nest
the worker ants of the raided nest will
become slaves
they'll spend the rest of their lives
working inside the nest of the raiders
even the larvae and pupae once they
emerge as adults will emerge as slaves
working on behalf of a colony they are
not related to
ritualized combat can be found in other
insect species as well stock-eyed flies
get their name from the incredibly long
stalks that support their eyes and
extend outward in opposite directions
from the sides of their heads
a malaysian species teleopsis domini
gather in the evenings on roots that
stick out along eroding stream banks
while both males and females have long
eye stocks the eye stocks of males are
much longer why because the females like
wide-eyed males
the longer a male's eye stalks the
better his chances of finding mates and
passing his genes on to the next
generation
as a result of many generations of
discerning females
males have evolved highly exaggerated
eye stocks
males compete with one another for
access to the roosting sites where they
have the best chances of finding females
but rather than physically fighting the
male with the longest eye stocks wins
these competitions getting access to the
mating grounds
if the difference in eyestock length is
great the victor is obvious and the
territory is seated without a challenge
but if the males are similarly well
endowed
a ritualized tournament ensues in which
both flies confront one another head to
head
turning side to side while keeping their
eye stalks parallel
once they have determined which male has
the longer eye stalks the loser leaves
without a physical fight ever having
occurred
as we've seen insects have remarkable
behaviors that include complex and
sophisticated forms of communication
from the waggle dances of honeybees to
the chemical messages ants used to find
food and defend their nests and the
ritualized combat of desert honeypot
ants and stock eyed flies
these behaviors are fascinating and
critical to the lives of these insects
and they've also inspired people to
develop computer programs that behave
like ants to make delivery routes more
efficient
given that there are more than 900 000
insect species alive on the planet who
knows what other technologies and
innovations may come from what we're
still learning about insects
in the next lecture we'll take a look at
the most diverse group of insects the
beetles and ask a simple but profound
question
why are there so many